c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon bah
écoutez je vais tranquillement j'ai un
petit peu d'écho parfois de ton côté
donc
la taille mais y croire
m
et salue bonsoir à tous j'espère que
vous allez bien que vous avez passé une
bonne soirée une bonne semaine c'est
comme tous les vendredis soir 21h sur la
chaîne twitch très content de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle semaine
post draft là on est à huit jours
exactement 2 de la draft 2022 ont plein
de free agency mais bon ça c'est surfait
qui va gagner le titre ou vallée québec
du est nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
comme d'habitude de parler de joueurs
qui vont avoir une carrière nba qui va
faire arrêter d'ici deux trois ans et là
je suis en compagnie ce soir un habituel
infidèle on est avec dailymotion est
particulièrement enzo de l'équipe
dailymotion com en tueur
salut à tous bon sort attend ça va très
bien merci les lébous yankees comme
bouyer d'appeler état et nous depuis
quelques années moi
les gars ça fait quoi ça fait comme une
loterie de celle
où la faim en fait là et pas de prime
temps c'était 2000 qui pète notre
dernier pioche ou 2010jean je sais plus
à suis peu près quatre intrus comme au
sens que donc ouais ouais c'est ça
l'année pays griffin ou cas il arrive on
vend play-offs et après depuis plus rien
ouais je vous prenez 4 0 mais c'est un
15-0 convient pas mérité parce que vous
vous battez voir c'est vraiment l'idée
qu'à racheter à tous les matchs sont ils
sont minimes mais on peut rien faire
alors vous me dites de l'autruche jeu
steegen salut à toi salut dr alexander
mc coy c'est du cirque je trouve ta
question juste après salue le gun vous
me dites au niveau du son comme moscou
n'est pas ce que disent qu'il y avait un
son pour la draft un peu bas mais
j'étais saoul grippe à 3 heures du matin
allait être un peu à du jour
la branche et son casque donc
vous nous dites le son comme on comment
ils essaient du coureau et bonsoir à
tous alors je vois déjà une première
question rien à voir mais je suis le
plus gros fanboy de nick smith junior
alors que nick smith d'une lorenzo c'est
un joueur qui arrive l'année prochaine
dans la cuve et 2023 mais en faisant de
la ligue 1 et j'ajouterais en tant que
bon fan des pistols the stream fort ce
soir à nouveau cinq collègues qui
s'intéressent déjà l'année 2023
nommément 2023 vous devriez pas de top 5
non
sauf catastrophe parce que on t on n'est
jamais à l'abri je pars d'un cube
l'effet d'un fit avec heidi qui marchent
pas de problème de rotation enfin alors
on n'est jamais à l'abri de rien
mais dans top 5 j'ai cru comprendre
qu'elle avoir pas mal de monde moi
évidemment top 1 il ya monsieur victor
mais j'ai un certain scouts à l'oeil
pour la prochaine partie qui me qui me
plaît bien donc avoir à voir qu'est-ce
qu'est ce qu'on donne les projette déjà
et on verra je vais vous qui sont placés
repartiront y avec scott henderson du
coup à anne et moi ce coup tf1 tu as
fait je vois puis j'ai découvert avec
vous alors qu'il a fini les pour une
night que je m intéresse avec lui et
franchement j'avais surkiffé mois le
petit scout âge le surkiffe après je
pense pas que même si on pouvait le
prendre on le prendrait lui parce qu'on
a beaucoup de monde sur les lignes
arrières mais avoir avoir qui la donne
et mais montre que je le kiffe c'est
l'un des joueurs que je suivrai alain
porcher noces moi c'est mon joueur
préféré de l'année prochaine et je pense
qu'il va peut-être être un devant
l'histoire et devant une bannière
impossible le monde parce que noah a
causé que des lois parce que ça peut ça
peut se discuter victor et vous coupent
blessés et ses amis et que scout est
juste exceptionnelle après on va en
discuter mais c'est un bol engler mais
qu'es tu peux très bien jouer pour une
fois au world et a presque coûté 900
stupeur en scoot henderson france coûte
henderson au pire sa phase est pas trop
mal et dont le chat qui nous disent quoi
le son est parfait donc moi c'est très
très bien parfait au dic c'était bien je
m'enflamme un petit potin que c'est
parfait
je cracherai pas sur derek white et dans
5 tu m'étonnes mais je pense que les
pistols peuvent viser mieux que quatre
top-5 et en tous cas à montrer des
objectifs compétition avec pas mal de
sites sur free agency
un petit peu parce qu'on va c'est ça le
sujet de ce soir vous l'avez dans le
dans le titre on va faire un requiem de
la draft mais pas que de la draft 2022
on va aller un petit progrès des scouts
avaient fait en 2021 en 2020 et points
comme on voudra fêter comment vous
développez
votre vraiment contexte jeunes mais la
free agency pistols pas trop mal et on a
laissé tomber l'option dit andré donne
coûtera maximum belle volée 10 est en
prison donc finalement on se rabat sur
des vétérans assez solide
ben on pour être honnête hier du coup il
ya parfois des prêts dès l'ouverture
franchement on éduque et beenox et j'ai
soufflé hautement qui nous la donne
oui et pourquoi en fait je vous en fait
on stagne à notre projet weaver du
beaver lui-même a déclaré vouloir
intégrer des vétérans confirmés autour
de nos jeunes joueurs sachant que du
coup il nous restait une seule place
dans le roster après la prolongation de
ma rue de beugler qui prend t-il
villenauxe je comprends pas un peu trop
l'intérêt j'aurais préféré un vétéran
plusieurs autres bandas treiber qu'on a
coûté au hong hao ligne que tu te dire
ok c'est déjà bien mais il n'y a
vraiment pas de vétérans confirmé tu
vois le plus vieux il me sens que c'est
c'est qu'aux jo il a 32 ans donc ça fait
ça me fait un peu chier d'avoir pris
kevin knox il ya moins que les choses
bougent la trade peut-être que coach je
vois partir peut-être que pollinique va
partir on sait pas mais je j'espère
vraiment qu'on va amener de l'expérience
autour de sa
banque et
peut-être mieux viser l'on attendait
juste parce que dans le le tchad vous me
le dites aussi je veux juste aller mieux
toutes les notifications discorde parce
que ça va être juste l'enfer pour les
gens qui écoutent ça d'avoir des to look
toutes les cinq secondes je le fais très
très discordants que les travailler
alors comment je fais ça
ouais vous avez récupéré donc du coup
les relais ce noël et notre ami birks de
new york ça pour le coup c'est les
signatures pour lesquelles tu es un peu
plus un peu plus contents non oui bien
sûr ben surtout narines ce noël qui va
pouvoir apprendre un peu le métier de
défenseurs que ce soit à turenne à
stewart parce que noël je trouve que
c'est un des pivots défenseurs et puisse
coûter de la ligue il fait un excédent
table 1 ah oui moi il me fait kiffer
défensivement noël 1 franchement il fait
une excellente ap il peut même traite
avec difficulté sur les meneurs mais sur
un sur un poste 3 il peut il peut se
traite eu peu il peut il peut il
défendre sur eux donc franchement ça ça
me fait du bien de l'avoir je vous dis
je vous dis qu'on a quelqu'un de doux
mais de métier un plus noël à quoi déjà
connu weaver à oklahoma city lorsqu'ils
étaient ensemble tous les deux donc je
pense que la cohabitation
travail entre tous entre tout cela va
bien marché et j'ai hâte de voir ça même
prix berck en vrai treiber que excellent
shooteur à un mètre à côté de cai de
j'ai vu j'ai mis beaucoup de fans
d'épisodes duroueix ou enlever au bout
du banc je suis vraiment pas sûr que ce
soit au bout du banc je pense qu'on va
voir une vraie place dans la rotation
parce qu'à côté de kate et à côté de hi
fi tout ça c'est fait exactement ce
qu'il te faut oui un jour qui peut jouer
qui va jouer qui
à montrer des vêtements loin du ballon
qui peut défendre et à une seule comme
tu l'as dit va apporter delà de la
rigueur on était un mec très jeune comme
durer un petit peut-être ne jouera pas
en première année beaucoup très très peu
et stuart questionnaire sur la troisième
année de 10 est ouverte si j'ai des
potes conneries
la deuxième il a appris à bout que c'est
fort donc la troisième on espère qu'ils
puissent développer un petit peu sentir
plus outils de rugby eh ben c'est ben
vrai déjà première saison il commençait
un petit peu à shooter et on se disait
ouais pourquoi pas les chutes étaient
mal pris mais tu voyais que que il avait
l'envié est là elle est la technique en
deuxième saison sur sur les trois
premiers quarts de la pré-saison il
absolument pas son le ont eux ont leur
ai juste et au poste d'intérieur et avec
l'arrivée de ben ali et du coup les
séquences qu'il a dû jouer au poste 4 et
là il a pu reprendre un peu du large par
rapport au panier et s'exprimer derrière
la drire la ligne et on a vu que ben
c'était quand même une menace non
négligeable ça c'est pas le joueur c'est
pas le joueur ou tu vas te dire un non
lieu l'espace à l'impossible mais il
peut en mettre un ou deux parades quoi
et franchement s'il peut développer cet
aspect là du jeu c'est tout bénef pour
nous comme pour lui je suis totalement
d'accord que je mets en quoi washington
qui qui était un gros défenseur vraiment
bell mobilité belle assiette est un qui
coûtent pas cher en plus donc tu ça ça
ça se garde totalement midi dans le chat
alors roger des exclusivités de résultat
du match de l'équipe de france +2
free agency alors c'est stefan des bulls
on est des rivaux ce soir mais on a
l'amour on m'annonce que derrick jeunes
juniors pro chicago bah écoute très bien
on avait les peurs du dessus donc j'irai
voir ça après je suis très content et on
nous dit oui vous avez alors là parce
que c'est pas un jour drafté mais c'est
un jour que vous avez récupéré ensuite
on arrachera grave vous avez récupéré
marvin bagley nous avait promis sur
trois ans je crois c'est ça à trois
grands de 34 millions ces deux minots la
saison pour une seule chose
est guère au delà du tout mais vraiment
très heureux
je pense du projet qui peut ce qui peut
s'intégrer à cette équipe de detroit
mais totalement parce que mise à part
cette équipe et qui est aujourd'hui le
duo avec kate une gamme baghli c'est le
joueur le plus capé des bleus comme je
dis souvent quoi dans l'équipe d'algérie
peut jouer pick and roll c'est une
doctrine il est athlétique ils peuvent
trek
c'est vrai actuellement c'est le
meilleur intérieur qu'on a à mettre à
côté de quelqu'un comme donc c'est
parfait pour nous de l'avoir lui
s'éclate il se découvre à nouveau rôle
qu'il avait pas forcément à sacramento
il se découvre une confiance il n'a pas
la pression
franchement là vendu un peu moins de 20
matchs qu'il a joué 16 matchs avec nous
la semaine dernière des 16 matchs ou où
on était ou moi pour ma part j'étais
impressionné je le voyais je le voyais à
sacramento plus maladroit plus timide il
arrivait au cayston s'il a une confiance
mais de malade et j'ai kiffé le voir
jouer donc j'ai vraiment hâte de voir ce
que ça va donner avec une préparation
complète avec une équipe qui connaît
mieux et l'a enrôlé mieux défini surtout
clermont en plus c'est bon on peut on
peut faire un parallèle avec les griffin
c'était une composante était pas mal si
les on a vu que les finales dit faut
être savez savez plus fonctionner
place défensivement qu'il avait des
difficultés qui se bougeait pas les
fesses mais tu as fait des recrutements
comme tu le disais sur le poste 5 a
vraiment intéressant tu peux très bien
jouer avec marvin bagley
ekaitz plus heavy sur les postes
arrières et hebei à l'intérieur et puis
après tu peux jouer un peu plus petit
avec bagley qui justement sur le banc
donc tu as vraiment une grosse
polyvalence et je pense que c'est une
des choses qu'on va souligner ce soir
c'est que la vôtre draft vous bon vous
avez eu de la chance d'avoir un premier
choix de draft
l'an dernier vous avez la chance de
n'avoir ivy qu'il essaiera curieusement
parlée par les kings cette année
j'ai l'impression qu'a dit white on
essaye dagan même d'avoir des joueurs
complémentaires qui peuvent jouer sur le
ballon loin du ballon avec de la
polyvalence des deux côtés du terrain
dans leur capacité à switcher jours
plusieurs positions à attaquer
effectivement and blood bowl toit du si
tu devais parler de la draft des pistons
sur les trois quatre dernières années
depuis l'ère trois heures qu'est-ce que
tu ferais sortir en avant qu'est ce qui
te marque qu'est ce qui te fait kiffer
moi ce qui me fait kiffer c'est vraiment
l'intelligence de weaver et l'on sent
que le gars travaillent derrière c'est
tout con mais l'année dernière quarante
septième choix il me semble on
récupérera lisa leavers est ici
totalement avec l'équipe insu angie en
devenir qui a montré de très belles
choses en un quart de saison car été
blessés et pour te dire on avait un gars
comme clan jackson qui était le
peut-être le deuxième est un shooter en
catch and shoot de l'équipe jusqu'à
l'année dernière ben si les chiffres
jackson n'est pas resigner est agent
libre aujourd'hui c'est aussi parce
qu'un gars comme à diverses a su montrer
qu'ils étaient présents qu'il pouvait
convenir et prétendre à un poste dans
l'équipe
en être weaver là depuis trois ans il
t'a drafté quand même fatigue behazah
stewart
killian
et et atteindra tekken light ivy et
turenne pas franchement sur les draft il
n'y a absolument rien à dire absolument
réagir même en deuxième tour kurita
choper un look à gaza bon on a vu que en
nba il n'était pas taillé pour était pas
adapté mais ça a été un bon gars dans le
groupe avec qui avec la ville investit
avec l'équipe à chaque fois qu'il rentre
et il se donnait à 20% même sa belle dit
je vois sa peine ni qu'on a draftés qui
a fait plus de matches et que la
g-league cac avec l'équipe première
en soi que je sens qu'il ya un petit
truc tu vois c'est un mélange explosif
intelligent qui sait shooter donc non il
fait y ait vraiment tous ses choix de
l'europe ont été intelligents et j'ai
bien aimé et
franchement sur le graphe ci est
absolument rien à dire rien à reprocher
sur votre hiver pour l'instant ce qui
est intéressant c'est que à chaque fois
cette grotte ils essayent d'aller sur un
énorme potentiel quelqu'un de très fort
tu l'as dit qu'eads hi fi ah non la
durée nilan a eu deux même quand il fait
bien il ya le raf ii qui donne moment là
et à côté de ça tu vas chercher des
joueurs safe de chercher des joueurs
expérimentés ainsi qu'ils ont montré des
choses qui sont des spécialistes wings à
ben lee vanderbilt très rapide hyper
explosif tu sais que tu pouvais amener
de l'agressivité tu vas sur sa digue b
villanova programme hyper sérieux
souviennent dit tu sais que tu as amené
de la la fluidité de la duel défensif
les anecdotes qui était jeune mais qui
avait en plongée de poudre 2 eme runner
tous savaient que tu pouvais amener ça
aussi donc effectivement c'est un ca
mais qui tuent sans travail toute
l'année on sait que dans le monde de
cocorico dans le monde du du scouting de
dit ouais tiens aux français qui
travaillent donc sur big ma vie on avait
tourné l'an dernier avec lui pour eux
pour parler de votre draft avant que
vous preniez kaid si on doit faire draft
par draft je te propose on remonte au
départ de 2022 et on redescend fur et à
mesure allez on sait que le coeur de
votre projet c'est kate mais là cette
année vous aviez au départ un premier
choix le cinquième choix vous aviez
turin migrantes dans un qui avait été
transféré ce terrain vous c'était quoi
qu'est ce qui ressortait un petit peu
des communications avant qu est-ce qu on
chercher du côté de dit white est pour
toi en quad et donner vie répond nous ne
répond pas à l'objectif initial de
detroit
bah faut savoir que que trop que trop
hiver a beaucoup fait parler le marché
avant de se décider sur ivy 1,5 il a
même parlé de creil daoud un moment
parce que lui vraiment ils étaient sept
enfants sur jane brain et voulait
c'était vraiment un objectif pour lui et
il est ils avaient ils se sentent et qu'
il nourrit il n'aurait pas hésité à
sacrifier ivy entre guillemets pour
récupérer du renne et d'autres capoter
donc moi ça me faisait un peu peur au
début parce que voilà ivy pour moi c'est
le gars à mettre à côté de kate il est
un peu il ment il ment que je tire une
distance je trouve mais c'est un
staffeur kiki qui a encore une marge de
progression shoot qui sait défendre
qui sait aussi jouer avec le ballon de
temps en temps c'est vraiment le type
derrière tu dois mettre à côté de kate
j'avais peur de récupérer celle de sharp
parce que pour moi je donne tu chantes
open ça aurait été un non fit ça aurait
été vraiment le le
comment dire la soirée pas marcher il
fait pas assez les efforts il a besoin
de la bad la besoin de cliquer et plus
créé pour lui même que pour les autres
et c'est pas du tout et que la mentalité
qu'on est en train de créer actuellement
donc j'avais peur de me retrouver le
seuil d'une chappe parce que je pense je
suis sûr que ça allait mal se passer
d'ailleurs là ils allaient au buzzer
pour lui c'est parfait parce que il a un
mentor à la personne dame du lac qui
fait que
indéboulonnable devra se mettre au
diapason pour lui et je pense que c'est
bon c'est quelque chose de bien pour lui
mais mais j'avais peur de montreux avec
lui on parlait aussi de mafieux de
lui je l'aimé beaucoup j'aimais beaucoup
son profil de gros gros twin dit
j'aimais beaucoup ce profil a à m en
poste 4 à côté de deux baies et kate
mais le sol soir de la draft quand je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait trois de
cul et je me suis dit non lui je ne veux
pas lui je ne veux pas et aller à trop
de kuyssche désole un cachet de leur
entreprise pour moi cela
la déclaration quand ils prônent james e
il est venu avec une sacoche n'affiche
pas une panade pour m
voilà le genre qui dégaine ces personnes
je vais faire le fanfaron sur le tapis
rouge la draft c'est bon c'est pas chic
en quoi et comment il a lâché le mot
fanfaron et la laïcité harmonise les
jeunes
mais pour moi c'est pourquoi c'est pour
ça que vraiment car quand on a eu des
actes et hyper content et soulagé pour
pour utiliser le bon moi je te rends
soulagé parce que pour moi c'était le
bon choix à faire enfin qu et après
alors quand on a eu du raid mais là
c'était la master class et t'es quoi
qu'il arrive la soirée a été réussie
donc nous nous on a vraiment peur que
weaver tente un énième paris il a
quasiment tout gagné c'est paris mais on
a peu fatigué des pavés on aurait plus
de sûreté mais et donc du coup je suis
je suis vraiment se rassurer
nous dit quelqu'un qui dit moi je
défends le choix des kings est quelqu'un
répond toute la commune pistone se
défend le choix des kings de produits
jeunes me
régale à zahlé pas venez pas soutenir va
vous n'allez pas aller contre les kings
qui vous laisse notre ami il a benn
mathurin pour ceux qui qui ont pas la
décla et l'a dit j'attends de voir enfin
j'attends de jouer contre les bruins eux
pour qu'ils me montrent que qu'il est
meilleur que moi bon c'est du bnd match
ira dans le texte un c'est un gars qui a
très forte confiance en lui qui il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de charisme qui
vont très très bien qui dégage quelque
chose et qui est tout le temps là dedans
donc c'est pas c'est pas surprenant
ivy tu me disais tu aimais bien aux
travaux chez dunlop parce que ça joue
loin du ballon pour toi actuellement
alors bon je suis d'accord avec ça je
pense que la réponse est là c'est clair
c'est pour éviter les balles donc je
tends la main de kate et ensuite le
deuxième porteur de balle de l'équipe
s'était donné vie ou vraiment toi tu
veux développer un joueur avec vraiment
le swing ndi excellent qui bouge partout
qui cotent partout où tu aimerais tu
penses que sa collègue steve offert de
développer un deuxième porteur de balle
pour avoir vraiment un monstre à deux
têtes et des joueurs à côté de voir
hyper athlétique ce lundi autour d'eux
les jours je pense que développer
développer jada née fissure sur la
gestion de la balle ça ça sera une arme
une arme incroyable à voir sachant qu'on
à killian sur le banc après tu vois donc
je me dis on a trois joueurs capables de
créer de porter la balle de dribbler
d'être vraiment une triple menace et moi
il ya quelque chose dont les gens ne
parlent pas assez c'est l'évolution de
sa digue b entre son année rookie et son
année sophomore avec tapas la main c'est
à dire que première année fatigue b
c'était le catch and shoot c'était
vraiment il faisait ça ou alors il
utilise sa vitesse pour aller au drive
mais c'était à fait limités
offensivement
des gens super league l'année dernière
il avait commencé à profiter de la
faiblesse entre guillemets des
adversaires pour jouer tout seul en iso
provoqué le drame puis le kick
développer une autre facette offensive
et cette année on a vraiment vu un
fatigue b alors avec la balle géante est
sans fin d'un match contre orlando à 51
points
il a dû catch and shoot mais il ya aussi
je prends la balle je demande l'iso et
j'attaque balle en main et je pense que
là pour les pistonnés la mission
offensivement ça va être de créer une
osmose collectif
on a on a vraiment des joueurs
intelligents
et je pense que la balle devra dans tous
les cas passés par la main de tout le
monde pour que tout le monde puisse
contribuer offensivement et j'aimerais
beaucoup que on se concentre cet aspect
là de judo de devenir une référence que
je trouve que offensivement on a un très
beau jeu déjà l'année dernière était
excellente et excellent avoir même sa
paire d'eon qui fait voir les matchs
cette année on a essayé de mettre
graines en avant donc avec de plus en
plus 10 ou donc c'était un peu plus
chiant à regarder mais passée la trade
deadline grain c'était sidelined et on
pouvait jouer c'était agréable à voir je
pense que on peut prétendre et on doit
viser à devenir on a eu les spurs puis
on a eu les warriors je pense qu'on doit
être une nouvelle
référence de jeu si on veut vraiment
mettre tout le monde à contribution
alors les pistes c'est une ou dix jeux
offensifs offensivement sommes pour que
les gens qui sont là bas on a même pas
mal de fans des pistes en ski qui
viennent avec nous ce soir on a aussi
beaucoup d'observateurs extérieurs
nguyen sinh les pistols offensivement
c'est quoi le fond de jeu même
défensivement c'est quoi le fond de jeu
et en quad j'ai donné vie pour le coup
particulièrement trompe pas trash ordure
elle s'intègre là dedans à tes yeux et
sur quoi tu as ta de plus
d'interrogations
alors offensivement le jeu il est il est
clair et
on va faire tourner la balle jusqu'à
avoir la bonne coup le bon drive
l'espace à prendre est très très souvent
on va avoir dès qu'ils calent elle pour
prendre le tir ça va vraiment être basée
sur le jeu collectif
cette année on a eu une des pires
adresse de la ligue mais ça montre aussi
qu'on a eu une volonté de tirer et pour
être honnête nous tire était bon c'est
juste que nos joueurs étaient pas en
confiance mais nos tyrans soient ils
étaient bons
donc on a vraiment un début de d'osmose
collectif qui fait plaisir en est a
surtout un caïd qui est très rarement
dans les highlights est très rarement
parmi les joueurs qui vont qui vont
aller dunker sur un joueur qui vont
creuser ça mais qui va être très smooth
qui va très calme très mature moi il me
fait penser à moindre mesure à un don si
c'est à dire avec un rythme lent
lui-même il avait fait une interview sur
le magazine slam le mois dernier où
lui-même se comparer à luke adam situe
dans un gestion de la balle donc je
pense que notre jeu va tendre vers
quelque chose à ce que ressembler mavs
c'est à dire
un porteur de balle dominant va faire
jouer les autres et des sentiments par
sur lui au maroc beaucoup de
communication beaucoup d'entre aide
beaucoup de switch un joueur comme
kilian aujourd'hui est très très bon en
défense et switch souvent sur des postes
3 4 sadji cube est très bon en défense
sûrement d'autres défenseurs le plus
polyvalent actuellement aussi donc c'est
le steward qui est qui et qui qui tend à
devenir un très bon film protecteur
aussi malgré le fait d'être under fife
notre soucis défensivement c'est
clairement les robots on se fait manger
au rebond lorsqu'on a un pivot dominant
je pense à jason a dit michelle robinson
a du beau père
qui dès qu'on joue contre eux en a en a
on se fait mais mais fumer au rebond et
c'est un peu on se tient ça que la
présence de noël me rassure un peu plus
c'est à dire que là où on va partir sur
un projet de win un projet de long va
inculquer la culture de la gagne je me
dis que qu'entre le new york par exemple
il ya michelle robinson en face ok on va
pouvoir maintenir un site web pour pour
pour le faire chier et c'est pour ça que
la présence de noah ne rassure et me dit
qu'on va un peu plus vers une politique
de la gagnes tu leur enlève nouvelle
donc forcément ça peut se le farcir toi
tu avais mal un thé ça vous devriez
écouter de 15 qui vont comme vous l'avez
fait il ya deux ans c'était sa technique
en fait de prendre tous les pivots pour
plus qu'on vous preniez rebonds
cette attaque que tu décris
effectivement tu as beaucoup de ivy loin
du ballon mais c'est ce qui faisait très
bien tu côté de pure audio radio qui ça
sortait des écrans très bon pour se ré
accès dans l'axé du panier déclenché à
trois points effectivement derrière
partir sur une ligne ouverture aux
exploser les kick out driver est monté
et finir jours tout le monde parce qu'il
est hyper explosifs très très bon déjà
dans le tas pas cité a changé de mains à
finir avec les deux mains droite -
gauche tu le disais tout à l'heure tu
avais tu avais venir bosser il manque de
mi distance il n'a pas cette capacité
pour le moment à se créer son écart
shorts pull up mais comme c'est kate qui
aura majoritairement la balle on va lui
laisser le temps de le faire et puis tu
auras kilian est effectivement tu auras
quelques autres satie gbeho bon au bon
souvenir de dirhams migrantes
et défensivement d'un joueur qui
effectivement on peut switcher
aujourd'hui un deux trois caps a été
hyper rigoureux
avec audio mais en même temps qu'il
avait beaucoup de responsabilités
offensives donc moi j'ai aucun doute sur
le fait que ça arrive ensuite à faire
cette transition lente et à terme aurait
donc développé c'est ce qu'il se bat
laon - c'est un joueur comme on le
disait plusieurs fois dans l'année qui
en interview est très conscient de ses
faiblesses il le dit il se compare à dia
mort un de mes dix mots contre 1 mondial
murray moi j'ai pas cette capacité à
faire du blow up à à ralentir on va
parler de kayes d'après midi hier fo
l'ont en fait la force de ces joueurs là
non pas un premier pas hyper explosif
c'est qu'ils sont capables de varier
tout le temps de vitesse donc même si
c'est pas un rapide bain tu fais rapide
lent moyens accéléré décéléré tu casse
tout le temps la vitesse de drive
tout-etat changement de direction est
ton rythme et donc c'est très dur à à
tenir avec un volume physique il ya plus
puissant lui à ivy on est sur un tgv
pour l'instant il va devoir nyons et son
jeu mais on a du temps pour ça tu
parlais de duren as tu parlé donc de
rebond tu parlais de rotation intérieure
tu parlais de noël tu parlais de stuart
effectivement le deuxième choix de cette
cuvée 2022 ses challengers n
pivot de memphis
fois déjà à ce que tu peux nous rappeler
le contexte comment vous récupérer ce
joueur et qu'est ce que t'en as tant
qu'elles sont pour toi les faiblesses
quels sont pour toi les points forts et
un petit peu déjanté zone de doute sur
ce jour ce joueur et sur le profil a dit
white alors battu rennes on l'a récupéré
pour la première étape ça a été de
refourguer grenth à portland en ne
récupérant aucun joueur qui nous a
libérés du cap premièrement ce qui nous
a ensuite permis
de
d'absorber le contrat de kemba walker de
de kemba walker
lors de
du trade avec new york et donc récupérer
leur pique aussi et new york s'est
dérangé parce qu'ils ont aussi récupéré
du cap pour pouvoir signer brunson et du
coup on a récupéré le pic de new york
contre rien du tout donc nous sommes
faits plaisir
et ensuite on a pu avoir le challenger n
djendjen qui était un objectif de wever
parce que c'est un pivot
un profil différent de ce qu'on a dit ce
qu'on a déjà avec stewart et baghli et
maintenant noël
c'est un pro c'est vraiment le moi je le
vois un peu comme un chien de garde
qui va se battre qui va apporter
beaucoup d'énergie
je le vois comme un pivot qui a une
bonne lecture de jeu avec ses écrans
avec ses rôles qui peut qui peut se
montrer agressif au panier
mais là où j'ai des doutes sur lui ça va
être dans son dans son utilisation avec
la balle
est-ce qu'il va réussir à faire le
décalage nécessaire pour trouver un
couleurs de drive est ce qu'il va
réussir à h pas à changer d'aile
rapidement pour renverser le jeu s qui
varie sans même avoir la balle en main
pour jouer au poste contre des
défenseurs de taille adulte de
musculature adultes et d'expirer
d'expérience un peu ça peut les hommes
de doute que j'ai sur lui je n'ai pas de
doute sur sa finition je sais qu'il
acharnée que ça il peut la travailler
même encore mieux mais c'est dans
vraiment et il va devoir faire le lit le
taf avec la balle où j'ai peur je pense
que ça va être un joueur sur les sources
et sur ses premières saisons qui va
perdre beaucoup de balles et fin je
redoute un peu donc hyper intéressant
effectivement des années du règne pour
ceux qui n'ont pas le profil ou donc si
on pas encore qui que de cet accord
parce que vous avez le découvriront ce
me redit que et puis après je vois les
prochaines données aux pistols c'est un
joueur qui sort de même fils qui avait
un an de moins que quasiment tout le
monde il a été reclassifiées pour
pouvoir faire la saison une 6è 2021 2022
normalement il aurait dû être de la
cuvée 2023 mais il a validé à cette
crédit il aurait y avait dix neuf ans le
sens de la draf donc lui la pub il a pu
se présenter c'est un joueur qui est
malgré le fait qu'il ait un an de moins
que tout le monde qui en avance sur sa
classe de draft physiquement c'est nous
mettre 11 113 kilos de muscles c'est un
joueur qui est vraiment bestioles qui
est pas un athlète verticale à la
hauteur de ce que pouvait être entre et
romain doublé gré final on nous avait
pas eu le plus jeune des griffin mais
dans des joueurs comme ça qu'on avait pu
voir aux pistons mais qui
par sa capacité à rester longtemps en
l'air à s'équilibrer vraiment un ntam
supérieur et peut finir poule est bonne
pour aller jour pas faire juste le
soutien et pour du joueur comme ça pour
être sur les comptes a cité il va perdre
beaucoup de ballons c'est clair et net
parce que c'est un mec qui a montré
qu'il avait un manque de fondamentaux
dans le jeu vraiment
inquiétant et qui est symptomatique d'un
jeune américain qui a tout cassé qui à
rallonge moi dans le sens où il savait
pas très bien où se placer il connaît
pas ses couvertures défensives que n'ont
pas ses couvertures offensive quoi il
capte un rebond ya pas de bac ça où tu
vas me voir rappelé andré drouin de cap
de beaucoup de rebonds mais qui fait pas
à l'écran retard le ballon il est
redescendu et donc les arrières adverses
sont juste à taper dedans et
interceptait la balle c'est hyper chiant
c'est vraiment des petites conneries
dans le jeu qui vont faire qu'au départ
il va pas être forcément positif
mais il va y avoir devant lui berne hans
noël stewart pour apprendre le métier et
parfois des allers retours geely
a démenti pour moi c'est un peu mon
micro malheureusement je crois que je
peux pas augmenter plus que ça mais
j'essaie de parler un peu plus fort et
par contre pour les lectures de jeu là
dessus moi je suis très très positif
pour pour ce joueur parce qu'on a vu
quelqu'un qui ici tout entier à la bonne
passe alors pour le moment comme il
manque deux fondamentaux la passe à les
envoyer dans la tribune les flammes mais
va que je vois mais il la voit tu vois
il lave en avant c'est à dire de la
manipulation visuel il sent le jeu par
rapport à ses attaquants à côté de lui
qu'ils tournent dans un système memphis
avec que des jeunes n'y avait pas de
fond de jeu ça change tout le temps
d'effectifs a changé tout en deux cinq
majeurs donc très difficile de créer un
cadre collectif vraiment serein en
deuxième partie danse était plus à
l'aise donc moi je pense que les tic sur
le rôle dans les corners comme tu lisais
pour sa digue bay pour donner vie pour
kidian aise ça va le faire au fur et à
mesure et dernier point que tu donnais
cette poste bas moi je franchement je
pense qu'il faut même pas essayé d'y
compter de prague roulé dessus c'est un
joueur qui n'a aucun fondamentaux de
poste bas qui a un bras roulé main
droite nos petits peut jouer un peu le
mismatch mais qui sait pas en fonction
au poste qui s'est pas placé les genoux
qui sait pas utiliser son dos pour
pouvoir vraiment et l'épaule pour
pouvoir vraiment te rentrer dedans donc
ça mon pour moi faut laisser tomber par
contre c'est du tir à mi-distance bien
vrai toucher est vrai fou dit et dans le
mouvement donc c'est peut-être un gars
sur lequel tu seras plus là dessus et tu
laisseras le post bac hyde tu laisseras
le post bassa type b tu laisseras le
poste bas marvin bagley et tenir à jour
un registre différent avec ghislaine
durel les yeux
je vois je regrette parce que c'est ce
que je pensais que tu valides un peu
les idées que je m'étais fait de lui en
regardant des extraits de matchs etc
mais après ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
que quand adil et il est très jeune
tu l'as dit au début d'émission ils
risquent de pas énormément joué cette
année et je pense que lui ça ne
dérangera pas plus que ça parce qu'ils
savaient que dans tous les cas est un
jeune en avance sur sa source à la
génération comme tu dis et surtout en
manque de fondamentaux et
il n'allait pas prétendre à une place de
titulaire dans une équipe nba de sitôt
donc sachant qu'on a on analyse nos elle
rencontra un poussin
moi ce que j'aimerais bien c'est que les
rênes à son temps pour un truc qui met à
apprendre le métier tu voir t abh à glee
est que après ont pu s'intégrer une
rotation avec les 3 à partir de l'année
prochaine ouais - clermont gérait là
dessus c'est un joueur qui va
effectivement pour se développer en du
dit c'est un joueur qui va apprendre
avec aussi votre coach
les bases du jeu qui se prononçait pas
poser des écrans qui font un vrai et
écart alors qu'il ya un mec on le
projette très bien sûr du hand of il va
très très bien le faire tu vois même
qu'ici jouer et des phases de hands off
où il passe le ballon hiva slip et au
panier pour essayer de nier quoi
répondre on sait pas encore bien intégré
mais on sent que ça va être il déserte
forte de son jeu donc tu vas pouvoir tu
vas pouvoir
épluchez dessus moi j'ai aucun souci là
dessus et en plus à terme toute offre
avec
kate et avec habitude offre un axe 1 5
défensifs vraiment très intéressant
parce que c'est ça que les pistons qui
vont les chercher où ses parts au
secteur de cercle et autant
offensivement le joueur si il devient
contenu on me dit las il fera toucher ce
serait de la femme dans un rôle à la
capella ci devient capella offensivement
oui ça peut être un peu décevant par
rapport à ce que tu as de base même si
moi je crois dans le tir mais tu essayes
d'avoir au minimum un défenseur plus
plus plus plus plus ce que peut être
capella et je pense que ça créera déjà
beaucoup plus d'écart pour kate qui va
encore pouvoir plus maximiser son jeu et
avoir des tirs faciles qu'on nous disait
au dessus je pense pas que kate ferait
une saison encore en en 50 40 90 20 avec
un vrai pivot 2000 on aura plus d espace
110 respect à stewart est pas répondu
d'un avis c'est des choses qu'ils
avaient pas l'an dernier qui manquait un
petit peu de la taille de la verticalité
un mec de 2,11 qui peut vraiment
sanctionné au cercle
c'est je pense que dans le développement
des piles tonnes c'est vraiment bien
alors après dans le côté mental il ya un
truc qui ressort c'est qu'ils tombent en
normalement on l'avait tous projetés
deux top 10 si tombant 13 ça veut dire
qu'on interviewe l'a peut-être pas bien
il a peut-être pas convaincu là dessus
mais ça mec très jeunes qu'il faut
former et peut-être aussi dense et voir
comment ces fondamentaux du jeu il ya
vraiment des grosses lacunes qui ont pu
freiner les franchises mais vous au pire
c'est idiot rennes ça marche pas pas
vous avez envie donc c'est un pari noah
laisse faire et qui vous coûtent rien
donc je suis vraiment fier vingt sept et
deux de ses choix l'a bien classé à la
summer league je l'attends mes deux
pieds faire non je te le dis aller
sachant que notre terre est sorti on a
quelques idées and magic built your eyes
vie jaden et c'est vraiment un
wiki et qu'il ajoute me demander
oui ben on attend juste que le le trade
show officiel
pour pouvoir l'intégrer à la rotation
officiel mais enfin où instant que celle
d'asseoir league mais oui devrait la
jouer
oui bien sûr où il est il est dedans
après j'avais eu lieu le soir de la
draft chez fitch des notes votre
incroyable il y en avait qui disait mais
kate va pas jouer c'était sûr mais
c'était sûr qu'ils allaient la jouer il
avait il à il a une préparation tronquée
l'année dernière à cause de sa cheville
il n'allait pas il n'avait pas craché
sur le fait de le remettre un peu plus
d'un bain peu plus en confiance avec ce
temps là après je me dis quand même ça
djigbé et stewart est qui et qui là
encore qui donne on peut dire que ça
prend 1 500 rookie c'est une fois saison
rookie parce qu'elle joue dix matches
mais ça hadji question où en summer
league en troisième saison
sa force
c'est sa il a l'impression que sur les
épaules on va pas tu écoutes on va pas
suivre l'autre c'est pas grave on s'en
fout on est là pour qui fait alors je
remercie tous ceux qui sont dans le chat
un je vous lis pas tout mais ça je
trouve des nombreux ce soir et c'est
plutôt bon signe donc merci à vous
d'être là et nous saluons nouveau comme
on réalise que je vois
allonge sûr on va sauter une année ah
non sur la dram de quillanaise joueur
français le plus haut de rater de
l'histoire des français 7e choix de la
draft qui viennent au moins
pour le moment il ya des déceptions il
ya des interrogations
qui lie à neige est ce que à l'époque du
trapel sur quoi il est drafté qu'est ce
qu'on en attend aujourd'hui quel est le
constat qu'on peut faire choper
lyonnaise et qu'elle projection va avoir
autant de rôles et en termes de
potentialités au pistols en à l'e3
est-ce qu'on est encore sur lui et bien
d attendre qu en année 1 est ce que
c'est normal pour toi lorsque tu vois
tous les jours d'avoir ce retard peut
être de développement et où est ce qu'on
va avec ligne après je te donnerai mois
la vie que j'ai dit au hamburger alors
alors déjà lorsqu'on le draft on voit
ans killian un joueur professionnel avec
des très bons fondamentaux
un qi basket excellent capable de pour
jouer un en deux et surtout un bon
défenseur là où on a fait une erreur
c'est que le poste de en europe et le
poste de aux états unis il est
totalement différent donc là a été notre
première erreur s'user killian à mon
avis et
il boit il arrive première saison déjà
personnellement je pense que la perte
des livres aux dons de saison rookie ça
lui a fait mal dans son développement ça
lui a fait très mal dans ce
développement dès le début de dès le
début des work-outs les deux étaient
très proches les deux avaient déclaré
qu'ils aimaient beaucoup que qu'il y en
avait dit que c'était une chance pour
lui d'apprendre aux côtés d'un d'un mvp
derrick rose est vraiment elle avait
pris sous son aile il fait tout le temps
ensemble et tu voyais que des grosses
voulait aider quillan à développer et le
fait d'avoir déjà perdu une figure à la
mène
qui derrick rose ça fait mal au
développement de cannes après il ya eu
aussi sa blessure à la hanche qui l'a
qui l'a embêté les trois quarts de la
saison qu'il a encore embêter
halla halla ode à la reprise de sa
saison sophomore en plus d'une blessure
au pouce
donc en deux saisons qu'il a n'a été pas
mal embêté par les blessures si on peut
l'excuser
mais manquent eux il manque
d'agressivité il manque de confiance
mais petit à petit
ils arrivent à se retrouver et surtout
en fait lorsque qu'il est arrivé on lui
promettait un rôle de meneur des pistons
sauf que le projet a totalement changé
sa djigbé s'est révélé kate est arrivé
donc forcément son rôle doit changer a
lui aussi on pensait on pensait pour
faire un bac kort kate pilotes sauf que
qu'il a n'a pas le shoot nécessaires
pour être aligné à côté de kate il a il
est loin d'avoir le nécessaire qu'ils
s'améliorent mais c'est pas quelqu'un de
fiable encore et au final son sa place
d'antan un temps que six semaines elle
est parfaite parce que convoi qui se
régale il se régale lorsqu'il est
porteur du ballon que c'est lui qui doit
faire le jeu
je pense sincèrement que en termes de
passe il est un poil au dessus de kate
c'est que je peux être honnête
il trouve des il arrive à débloquer des
situations plus compliquées que caïds et
là où kate va se débloquer lui-même en
n'allant pas nier qu'il y à elle va
réussir à vraiment trouver le décalage
la passe à faire le système a à faire et
c'est une des raisons qui je me dis que
qui donne sur le banc c'est sa place et
c'est là où il peut le plus amélioré et
on l'a vu sur la fin de saison dernière
le match contre aucun ici me semble de
tête où il mais il met un vent 8,8 il me
semble c'est c'est vraiment le client
qu'on attend agressif qui va au panier
sa finition main gauche comme à droite
sont de qualité et le jour où il y aura
le déclic le jour il aura le déclic qui
va vraiment
excusez moi du terme et sans lever le
bayer sans lever le bas est dû qu il il
va vraiment vraiment il va vraiment
devenir valu au bol il va vraiment
devient volley-ball parce que il va plus
il va plus vivre de ses coéquipiers il
va pouvoir être dangereux lui aussi est
pas plus grosses qualités qui le
distingue des autres c'est défensivement
pour l'instant pour moi ou il est
vraiment hormis les en tant que gold
parmi les meilleurs de la ligue pour moi
parmi vraiment le top 30 de la ligue il
est dedans
à clermont najjar prendre des éléments
de scouts à dire dans le chat on se pose
des questions comme ça me dit pistoles
04 sera streamé pour ça que vous êtes
excitant alors vous avez vu ma petite
peut-être l'écran qui vient réclamera
donc désolé pour ça désolé pour ça
très belle à merci mais j'ai des
commentaires exceptionnelle de
avec une très belle touch et c'est très
gentil de ta part ça se travaille à ce
travail c'est du grand pedigree ça que
kilian alors je vais essayer de vous
mettre ça en même temps sous les yeux
paul alors hop
la technique elle est un peu
rudimentaire ans excusez moi vous
connaissez
up est vraiment ça va ça va apparaître
sous vos yeux ébahis dont mademoiselle
faut que tu attendes pour lesquelles je
te ferai après
le lien 2
l'union envergure sûr qu'il y en a qu'on
regarde le scouting report vous avez
dans les points forts création pour soi
of the bubble
création présente sur une plaie making
et cetera poing gauche font un point
fait par nous excuser moi vous avez le
catch and shoot et cochez exclusif c'est
vrai que c'est peut-être le plus gros
truc pour
moins d'heures pour qu'il y en ait dans
son développement alors à tanger c'est
devant 6 annonce dans sa marche ouais tu
me diras retour situe là l'écran aussi
oui
quillane il est passé de créateurs
ballaman jour de poules up à jour de
catch and shoot avec l'arrivée de
quelques d'une gamme avec l'arrivée de
sabine becq homme se dit qu'ils étaient
plus expérimentés cave un parcours long
du côté de villanova avec gérald y avait
le ballon donc lui l'adaptation
elle a été compliqué là dessus il a
vraiment dû reprendre des habitudes
motrices n'étaient pas les siennes
effectivement belle relation
à t'acheter je te coupe rudy gobert
amini fatah non
mais non quoi fin mais non mais ces
dames vous vivez où est attendu un peu
de fans dévoués mais quand rudy gobert à
minnesota
n'est qu attendez-vous confirmé dans le
chat vous confirmez la
digos vers minnesota exceptionnel
et quoi mais wesh mais contre quoi même
si moi ou alors on va on va suivre ça on
va suivre ça c'est la faute
de qui viennent et on voyait tout nous
tout simple
je vais pisser je tombe sur ça
incroyable vous pouvez clip est là la
transition kids and the rudigoz vera
s'est confirmée ou album booba hâte de
voir les infos [ __ ] incroyable donc
quoi qu'il ya ni l'a vraiment d habitude
motrices à refaire un rôle à refaire lui
l'avait de mental était un peu de
ricains aussi je suis une meilleure
balle en main je peux me créer mon
propre une cire et tout est en fait sur
le terrain on a vu un joueur qui avait
des limitations à saxe accéder au panier
des difficultés qui est devenu un peu un
peu tendre et ça c'est vraiment plus
compliqué donc actuellement pour vous
ça mais quand sorti bon
c'est un gars qui est toujours un rôle
de sous il dit élites extérieures un peu
ce que faisait franck millet qui n'a
finalement et
pour moi en fait tu vois que kay dont on
va pratiquer d'après il est maximisée
camp et des fonctions les ailiers pour
moi c'est un point fort admet qu'il est
franchement les alliés et j'aimais
beaucoup l'idée d'avoir des line-up avec
kilian ivy sur les postes arrières bay
avec gabe et ensuite un pivot tu vois et
ça je pense que on peut la voir l'année
prochaine ça peut laisser une dernière
chance à quillan de mon maximiser du
temps de jeu un peu balle en main de
temps en temps avec vraiment haut débit
qui est loin du ballon et lui laisser
une dernière chance pour pouvoir
se créer cette réputation de porteur de
balle trop tard pour sa carrière
ouais je pense que vraiment il a un
vague on apprend après il a il a quand
même la grosse confiance du front-office
faut savoir que dès l'année dernière lui
saljic et stewart ont été prolongées de
leur contrat rookie or qu'il avait
encore deux ans pour le faire et
donc il ya ilahi là la confiance du
front-office dopent la confiance de
l'équipe faut savoir que kate tadjiks
tout et killian sont très proches en
dehors du terrain aussi
et
est donc il aussi là encore il a je
pense qu'il a encore deux saisons
devant lui pour prouver qu'il a sa place
pistols après ce sera compliqué si au
bout de deux saisons le projet commence
à décoller et que kilian ne suis pas
très compliqué pour lui fera forcément
sacrifier
alors on a là une unité de te coucher
les boutons mais je te coupe alors c'est
rudy gobert contre malick beasley pas de
beverly walker question le pivot de raft
et donc avant de la signature jared
vanderbilt et des fins plusieurs
premiers premier tour incroyable donc on
va avoir une paire car l'internet aux
radicaux verts on l'a vu en lui avec un
anthony tonnes ne voulait plus des
rencontres des pivots il n'aimait pas
trop le contact il aimait plus jouer au
large donc on va on va avoir la paire
rudy gobert anthony tonnes et on va voir
d'îlots et
anthony edwards et donc ils ont plus
plus plus plus du tout de bon
les veaux vie met tout sur le cinq
majeur ça va être ça va être la folie va
être incroyable ouais mais je suis un
peu deg pour pour gaubert parce que il
quitte demain michel qui est un
défenseur nul ouais pour 40e returns
cannes défenseur nul et en plus il garde
un prix donc
un peu des produits de cap qui vont
envoyer les mcdaniels de vanderbilt ils
vont il faut y aller
tandis qu'il y aille au talent inouï bon
ils vont aller sur mcdaniels épuisons
prix qu'elle anderson donc on va jouer
très gros on va jouer très très longs
mois et puis bon on va on va suivre ça
mais on en reparlera une autre fois et
utah effectivement part avec walker
kessler qui fêterait qui fêterait utah
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas nos qu'il
y ait effectivement on on a fait le tour
globalement joueur qui est assez loin le
joueur qu'on a là et le jour qu'on va en
faire est assez loin du mec qu'on a
draftés on s'est peut-être fait une
mauvaise idée de sa capacité à se créer
son tir en tout cas de sa capacité à
faire autre chose que du poulet point le
biais de pouvoir au niveau du panier on
aura toujours un joueur fonctionnelle
nous qui aurons un deuxième contrat sur
la même cuvée on a été pas mal pas le
csb je te propose en fait on va retourne
pas dessus parce que on a vu le gave
profil souviennent du massif capable de
défendre un dogue qui a montré des
progrès balle en main qu'il avait déjà
villanova mais qu'on lui a laissé le
droit de faire du côté de detroit avec
jérémy grande sur le côté je te propose
on va faire un focus sur kate parce que
c'est quand même la pièce centrale de
votre projet 4 koenig gamme il arrive tu
l'as dit c'est pas le plus flashy toi
c'est quoi qui t'excite le plus quand tu
vois quelqu'un une gamme c'est quoi que
tu vois que ocz de 10 à bien ce mec là
il peut être top 10 de la ligue est sûre
pour toi qu'est-ce qu'on développe
jusqu'à ce que des gamins dans la suite
belge devra encore une fois pour être
honnête il ya cette saison il ya
énormément de matches que je veux où je
vois quelqu'un je lui dis mais [ __ ]
mais il est trop fort je me dis n'est le
gars il a 20 ans ou 30 ou 35 ans il fait
il joue comme steel avait dix ans de nba
derrière lui une relation footwork
oodrive pour se créer de l'espace est
impressionnant à son âge encore une
encore il ya trois quatre jours je me
faisais une compile de ses drives contre
les big et sa création des espaces mais
elle est déjà élites contre d un bide
degobert des tonnes qui sont réputés des
bons des bons des bons défenseurs de
cercle il arrive avec aisance à se créer
un espace à finir ses magnifiques
vraiment qu'on voit quelqu'un une gamme
je vois le basket c'est vrai c'est pas
flashy il va pas avoir 36 highlight à
djanet green l'autre à jamhour end pour
gossip mais ça va être efficace il va
savoir qu'en faire n'a pas calé au drive
c'est quelque chose assez rare a
souligné pour un rookie mais il est très
très à l'aise omid wrench il va pas
hésité en plaindra il va monter pour
profiter de l'espace qui là pour mettre
une bride et il est assez épicé ans de
mandat j'ai rarement vu un groupe qui
triple menace est un
joueur de froid et ce coureur à trois
niveaux et moi quand je vois que je veux
dit mais c'est dr roux qui comme on en a
rarement vu c'est un art vin et et là où
havrais je te mens pas je vois pas de
point faible il faut pas vraiment
peut-être sa défense sur drive qui peut
améliorer
ils arrivent à contrôler ya pas de
soucis mais à offrir une vraie
opposition à la finition c'est encore un
peu compliqué je m'étais entretenu avec
son frère kanène qui était un plus son
coach assistant à
oklahoma
voilà voilà c'est ça caille jouer
d'aller jouer en est resté et il me
disait que le défi pour kate ça va être
de prendre du muscle de prendre du
physique pour pouvoir pour voir un peu
proposer une opposition à certaines
l'attaquant et on l'a vu sur cette
première saison où parfois tu sentais
qu'il manquait un peu des pôles un peu
de d'abdos pour pouvoir encaisser les
coups même quand lui va au drive tu vois
avoir un peu des pôles pour pouvoir
faire le petit bump qui va te créer de
l'espace a opposé donc c'est un peu le
un peu là où ou j'atteins de lui un peu
une
amélioration
dans sa dans son adresse aussi je crois
que t'as 40 % de mémoire en université
mais sa baisse d' adresser combrée ainsi
parce que la ligne est plus loin les
défenses ont pu dur donc tu peux
comprendre sa base adresse mais
j'attends quand même de lui qui
plante un peu plus même ça shoote
sélectionné est bonne mais après je vois
pas de défaut majeur il y avait pour
revenir sur tout ce que tu as dit à ma
petite qui est là décident de ce soir
d'être la plus qu'alain de la semaine au
moment où nos lacs la bonne rente est
trop belle demoiselle qui excuse moi
kate pour aller un petit peu de chances
que tadine en acier dans une équipe
assez de peintre or je pense que vocale
elle n'a pas pu tenir sa classe d'hommes
mais il est avec des golgoths physique
beaucoup beaucoup d'athlètes mais pas de
shooting peu de peu de bollène ligne
c'était compliqué pour ce jour là il
avait pas de pivot non plus donc on a vu
un mec qui a réussi à amener son équipe
a très très haut niveau avec un manque
de qualité de tir et de qualité de
création autour de lui alors à temps
parce qu'elle va juste tout me faire
tomber ah là là là où est fatigante tout
est fatigante mademoiselle up
pour les points faibles du joueur il y
avait pour le moment et tu l'as bien dix
ans un manque d'agressivité dans le dans
le dos au panier on est sur un porteur
de balle de plus de deux mètres
mais qui peut jouer poste bas et qu'ils
n'avaient pas le cas vais pas le la
mentalité pour enfoncer son défenseur
direct pour vraiment l'emmener sous le
panier et pour pouvoir le bulli ce que
l'ogaden si tu fais très très bien
entre autres est ce que à autre échelle
lebron james fait très bien sûr les
défenseurs plus petit que lui donc on va
attendre sa jaquette qu'une gamme pour
le tiers s'était même son gros axes de
progression par rapport
au niveau universitaire niveau lycéens
on avait un peu peur du tir sur toujours
le catch and shoot on n'était pas sur
quelque chose de très stabiliser et la
rive en nba et hier à 40 % même si le
volume est pas hyper conséquent ils
tirent à 40% et après en nba sur un jour
qui est très ciblé avec + 2/3 plus de
poules up de prix aussi on est quand
même sur eux une belle réussite donc ça
va être à développer toi parce que c'est
mon un peu mon cheval de nos cheval de
bataille tu pourrais faire quelques
bingham qui commence en défense sur des
ailiers qui est défendu par des ailiers
ou tu préfères kyle cunningham qui
commence en attaque sur des arrières et
il est défendu par derrière
ben moi je le trouve
en fait comme je le trouve très efficace
dans les daims dans l'utilisation des
mains en défense sur sur des mineurs sur
des arrières il je trouve qu'il est
assez beau interceptions pour une conso
nage et pas que sur les pas vraiment il
va il va chiper les ballons dans les
mains dans le dribble etc j'ai peur un
peu de brider
de brider cette force là si tu te fais
des peintres des alliés forcément les
alliés auront au moins la balle donc
moins de possibilités de
de
démarrer des contre attaques
et surtout en fait là où je me dis que
ce n'est pas une nécessité c'est que ça
gicle fait très bien le taf sur des
ailiers
là il ya grain quitter un bon défenseur
polyvalent aussi va savoir savoir
comment on va réussi à remplacer son
apport défensif
évidemment ce que je serais toi je
serais pas étonné que ivy killian et
kate joue en même temps sur le parquet
tu vois donc dans ce cas là oui kate
défendra sur des ailiers mais sinon
j'aime beaucoup le voir sur des mineurs
ok alors c'est vrai que moi tu vois j'ai
été plus au niveau niveau universitaire
est encore un emploi une bille fh sur sa
première sur sa première année
moi j'aimais beaucoup son second rideau
ans qu'il était toujours très très bien
placé et déjà mais très intelligent sur
la bonne route à le contre où bien le
passage en force l'interception sous le
panier et ensuite il pouvait relancer
rapidement le ballon avec une défense de
cercle il y avait des limites latérales
qui compensait genre d arrière par son
intelligence il orienté très très bien
mais il y avait comme des limites
latérales et
encore une fois mois sur les jours les
ailiers tu vois pour défendre des mecs
comme les bons en était troublé siakam
et que tu as gym et bien ça si nous
sommes en haut du corps pouvoir contrer
c'est le contact qu'il allait développer
et à contrario quand ils avaient la
balle en main les ailiers avait pas là
l'habitude de défendre contre un mec qui
pouvait faire autant de choses bat le
mans et il était un peu perturbé par
rapport à là où des arrières ont plus de
réflexes sur les changements de
direction et changement d'appuyer sur la
défense du pick and roll en fait tout
simplement aussi et non je trouvais
qu'on maximiser ses capacités la balle
en main face à des ailiers surtout dans
une défense nba où tu pouvais appeler du
coup maintenant des tidianes des ivy
pour lui poser les grands faire un
switch sur l'arrière ou obligatoire et
justement
permettre à quai d' une fois lancée sur
le pick and roll d'enfoncer l'arrière
adverse sur du genre trois jours du
drive cours maîtres de l'épaule avec la
gauche et finir à droite ça lui
permettait d'éviter de se créer tout son
action face à un arrière qui avait la
mobilité depuis la ligne à 3 points
jusqu'au palier ouais je sais j'ai
tourné motifs discorde et j'essaie de
muta depuis tout à l'heure donc c'est
insupportable je suis désolé pour ça
je n'arrive pas à la prochaine fois je
ferais autrement alors c'est parce que
j'ai pas dire ta gueule à tout le
discours de ils ont raison de chat et vu
comment la nba afin de partir en couille
et ce sera ce sera résolu la prochaine
fois j'ai scénique le truc mais mais
voilà pour qu'eads en tout cas pièce
centrale de votre de votre construction
pièce centrale du projet et je pense
qu'on peut avoir un futur candidat une
bille sur les cinq six prochaines années
en tout cas je vous le souhaite
je franchement déjà je pense que cette
année va être all star ou au moins
all-star caliber sais j'en suis sûr et
certain et mais oui vraiment quel est
l'apport de le joueur qui cogne
quiconque est une gamme la porte qu'il a
beaucoup trop son côté les gens ne se
rendent vraiment pas content de son
niveau encore il ya quelques mois on le
comparer à chris duarte et ar jones pour
te dire jusqu'où ça va et encore une
fois je gelé beaucoup dit cette saison
et je leur dis qu'est qu'une gamme
absolument pas mise en valeur par la nba
n'est absolument pas mise en valeur par
personne mise à part les fans des
pistols et alors qu'il est il est un
joueur mais tellement plus talentueux
que tous les autres qui dans sa draft et
comme j'ai dit il fait pas die light
n'est pas flashy mais merde il est super
fort le gars il est vraiment super fort
et j'ai vraiment j'ai vraiment envie que
mon deuxième saison pour sa deuxième
saison les gens se rendent compte du
talent qu'il a tu vois je est ce un
péché les gens vont dire oui la d3 à
détroit tout le monde peut stata et anna
mais personne au regard du match et du
coup personne se rend vraiment compte du
talent de l'intelligence de la propreté
du calme de la maturité et ça me fait
chier c'est un peu
la plupart des observateurs de la nba
savent que ken keen games est un joueur
exceptionnel et je pense que comme tu
parlais des le cas d'une cité des jours
comme ça
les faux lent maintenance fin avec you
qui tue encore plus si haut niveau une
vie peas étaient plus obligés d'aller
très très vite et de 24 heures pour
comprendre à quel point avec il est fort
et
et ça je pense que clairement quand les
pistols ou gagner des matches et les
pistols ou gagner des matches sur les
trois quatre prochaines années on est
assez persuadé là-dessus il n'y aura
aucun fraction de la visibilité en plus
tard amené à évita ramené de rennes pour
le côté baisses bestiaux athlétique
hyper physique qui vont monter très haut
dr atté light et tout le monde sera que
le chef de requins de cette équipe ces
quelques lignes gammon on mettre un peu
de respect sur sur ce jour là et à
quelqu'un qui nous dit je suis d'accord
j'ai pas regardé des toits étaient si
j'avais mater que les tops jane green et
plus talentueux barbry voilà ça c'est le
côté twitter est apte ces deux côtés
grande awa bâ bon après c'est m ont dit
c'est pareil pour des zones qui on
disait pareil pour beaucoup de joueurs
et finalement ceux qui viennent des
titres à la fin c'est quand même ce qui
qui font des actions de basket qui font
gagner des matchs donc vous inquiétez
pas là dessus et
et on aura des dépasse incroyable ce
qu'il ya des new look incroyable on aura
des groupes le parce que c'est un joueur
qui a des grosses grosses galoches et
qui va mettre des buzzer beater et qui
est peut-être déjà mis des besoins du
tout à être jugé pour garder tous vos
matches mais
les pêches il est très clair après le
après le all star game il faisait partie
du top 5 de la ligue en point dans les
deux dernières minutes du match monsieur
nostoc
en première mi-temps il ajouté à peu
près à 35 40 % en deuxième mi temps il
était à 45% sur le clutch time l'état
plus de 50 % aux tirs mais ils s'allient
pour ça ouais c'est un jour qui m c'est
un gestionnaire c'est un joueur qui aime
faire d'abord oublier les copains qui va
mettre tout le monde en bonne condition
pour que pour que ça réussisse alors je
vois des gens dans l'ue27 qu'ils
viennent pourquoi hier fois bienvenue à
vous excuser moi si je réponds pas tout
voilà il va refaire briller tout le
monde et puis au moment où il faut
gagner des matches il fera le pont plaît
et il prendra le ballon il saura tirer
avec efficacité c'était une des
questions qu'on se posait s'ils
pouvaient jouer quarante minutes de la
manière inouïe joue les dix dernières se
serait il serait top 3 de la deûle nba
tout le temps et ça qui va devoir
réussir à faire et j'ai pas de doute là
dessus un mec qui ne nous dit joue comme
un gars qui a tapé en euroligue pendant
deux trois saisons au rsa il joue quand
il joue comme un daron est en fait ce
qui est important de signaler c'est que
d'être connu une gamme doit toutes les
équipes du jeune tim ios est qu'ils
jouent avec jane green avec des scolytes
barnes avec des mecs plus vieux que lui
le patron c'était tout on lui avec den
sax de patron c'était tout le temps lui
donc il a toujours été le leader de
l'équipe le meilleur porteur de balle et
le franchise player de ses équipes
jeunes américaines donc il y avait
vraiment aucun doute là dessus
vraiment les gens les gens en vie mais
après ça me fait plaisir de voir que y'a
des gars comme chris paul comme qui
dirait même que plante à sec 1/10 père
curt le biais qui eux reconnaissent
vraiment le talent et 10 non mais les
gars regardez qu'est qu'une gamme c'est
un crack ito donc ça au moins qu'il soit
reconnu par ses pairs ça fait plaisir
après moi j'ai peur que qaïda détroit
rapidement envie de gagner et j'ai peur
que si le projet n'avance pas aussi vite
que ce que kate avance ça risque de mal
finir pour nous donc avoir avoir un peu
comme ça avance après ça mec a l'air
c'est assez stable ses fidèles très
professionnel qui est jouée dans une
petite flaque oklahoma state alors où il
y avait son frère mais tu es allé jouer
dans une plus petite fac il est pâle et
dans les crocs grosses écuries comme du
kentucky et cetera où donc pour moi il
s'adjugeait pas trop inquiète mme dati
mais le coach en avant ça c'est
important qu'ils se prennent pas pour le
dessus du costume est le coach n'a
jamais eu et bien sûr b et puis en plus
vous avez vous avez recruté là vous avez
drafté à iv vous avez drafté du rennes
où vous avez de la potentialité vous
avez kidian vous avez des finances qui
montre assez stable avec de quoi donner
des gros contrats par la suite non que
je pense qu'on a une situation idéale et
que dit toi et honnêtement parlant même
ça me fait chier en tant que fans des
bulls 1 mais que dit white honnêtement
parlant peut être une des plus grosses
équipes de la nba
d'ici 3-4 on est
convaincu j'en suis vraiment content
qu'on ait un projet hyper clean hyper
bien construit qui se porte à merveille
et j'en suis convaincu que des temps
maximum on a un titre c'est et j'en suis
convaincu a dit combien sept ans ouais
bon bah non mais j'attends vos clips et
ça et puis chaque année aux freenautes
iphone 5 en inde et donc il faut que
d'ici juin 2029 on la fin 2029 les
pistols et un titre en vrai bon je vous
souhaite donc les boutons non en 2028
moi ça me va et est un vrai c'est pas
improbable écoute on a fait un beau tour
d'horizon jeu
un petit quizz sur les joueurs draftés
par les pistes au dessus les leviers de
picolat
2010 2010 alors écoute est ce que tu
veux qu'on se fasse tous les jours
drafté par les pistols
on essaye janot tous rendus alors j'ai
pas réaliser un jeu le fait de façon
d'être sur la liste allait de 2022
2010a les attentions amélie a trahi du
coup il ya la seconde pour eux qui ont
les faits au cnit et second tour mais on
fait pas les drafted par exemple as tu
vois ces bonnes ni il ya une drafted
donc c'est bien david ça compte pas et
je te laisse la main et dont le chat
essayez de vous les notés en petites
feuilles mentale à elle est à l'évidence
que tu le défends ce n'est pas la
pression mais faut que tu n'es pas y
aller et j'étais coincé par kevin
cunningham ok bon ba agit
et qui analyse
alizade tu vois ça tu paies
spencer jean louis dit ok ok il prend il
prend des risques efront besoins en
drones
tobias à risque
on va aller sur un serial liver ce
brendan naik au dessus par directement
choisis moi ça marche et ça m'a enfin
on va aller légende henry evenson
[ __ ] je l'avais oublié
batakovic a
bien joué
comme des vitres c'est quoi ces florida
state moderniste en plus ouais c'est ça
au [ __ ] mais je constate choc
j'ai sorti tout ce que j'avais je pas
atteint ce que je peux trouver que ce
que je peux trouver fpi est ici puis ok
alors peut-être qu'il donne drafted donc
je vais me garder pour un petit peu
après je vais aller chez eux creighton
kate moss
au [ __ ] européennes ont fait un gros
navet amelio n'avait de l'espoir avant
lui
automatique 1,2 tonne
dans nos têtes nous dit stuart séide
raté par pourtant nous on fait pas
l'équipe qui mettront la casquette nous
fait l'équipe qui il le récupère le soir
de la draft
du programme de ses dents tchad jamais
triché un peu les peintures greg monroe
a bien joué alors est ce que nous dit de
ça c'est pas grave tu es pas milwaukee
voie mais il joue directement avec les
jeux directement pistone je vais aller
alors peut-être que je vais me planter
du coin tandis est de regarder ce n'est
pas un autre avant tout à la fois le
chat en même temps j'en ai pas déranger
un joueur rendre à petit c'est sur tige
ou chez vous
je crois que je crois que j'en ai deux
crises middleton drafté au pain à il est
drafté ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai
on t'a dit on par de 2010 c'est ça
qu'on est dur
à luc hennart tu me l'a volé avait
attendu quénard tu sais il n'y a pas si
longtemps
l on en oubliait un français il ya ce
coup alors les oui bien sûr on habitait
confiseries les canarder effectivement
évasivement reste un scroll blues brad
honywill me le prendre
iront couler
alors à temps du coup ils me font me
pousse bronn il va me rester qui a été
drafté trop tard par les palets pistols
et parti est devenu all star ailleurs je
sais votre spécialité ça quand même les
gars
parce que j'en ai un autre ou pas ou est
ce que je perds là dessus
je vais pas faire durer je pense que
j'ai perdu jordan bonilauri drafted ou
pas
voilà il me semble la lnd raciste je
vérifie je vérifier peut-être que je
perds chanteur donne bonne vision de
tennessee et je sais pas s'il est pas
une drogue style de facile et rapide ou
pas certains à un autre pour me terminée
ou non
je réfléchis
y visera fait il est drafté eibach
et je veux dire kyle singler kyle
singler incroyable bien joué moi car je
n'avais pas du tout quel signe alors je
vérifierai excuse moi parce que pour le
clavier mais ça me dit rien du touquet
singler
alors 34 ans oms que 34 ans et la draft
et j'ai mis le pas du tout cas bien
jouer ses forces et forbach où j'aurai
personne d'autre j'aurais personne
d'autre donc on va te on va te laisser
la victoire sur kyle singler excepté
alors qui est ce qu'on avait oublié on
avait d'autres là qu'on a pas qu'on a
pas citées je remonte un petit peu oui
8e
non non vous dis je
en fait ce qui est chiant c'est que
comme on a souvent eu la place du con à
la draft comme on était assez pâle 8e 7e
caunes aller en play-offs aux normes
drafté des gains en fait
c'était exceptionnel
inconnu au bataillon striji
hors pair
petite anecdote j'ai vu que j'ai vu
aujourd'hui en étant resigner michelle
robinson devient le premier mix à avoir
une extension ou qui depuis
1984 il semble depuis nick world depuis
j'ai moi j'en ai parlé avec un mot nabot
traite de la first il n'y a pas très
longtemps et je l'avais dit quand est ce
que les knicks il avait pas de prolonger
un gars et il avait dit oh [ __ ] de nom
et je l'avais dit m depuis des années 81
99 ouais alors on ne tutoie rniste
quitta pour moroni c'est que c'est l
épaisseur et bien joué
bon bah écoute tu gagne haut la main tu
gagnes pas la main bravo et c'était un
bon petit challenge et on pourra
rajouter quelques noms l'année prochaine
du coup pour la draft 2023 avec bédié
écoutez on va pouvoir s'arrêter là 22h06
moi je vais vous libérer pour aller
suivre la free agency et et voir comment
la nba va changer de visage avec
peut-être un un big three avec c'est pas
moi anthony davis qui rejoint jean
sérien les timbers à côté pour mon poste
3 pourquoi pas
je vous invite et du coup à les
rejoindre en tout cas les follow la
communauté de new delhi mme automne sur
sur twitter ça c'est fait diamond
exceptionnel faire du coup avec le riz
name et au où
vous accueillir avec plaisir
pour suivre l'actualité des futurs
champions nba 2026 du coût et du coup
pas que ça vous fait aussi maintenant
le baseball le hockey la nfl moi moi je
vais surtout m'occuper personnellement
de l'année fait des billets mais on est
aussi axé sur la culture de détroit
savoir qu'en fait ce qui est beau à
détroit actuellement c'est que déjà
toutes les équipes de sport se reforme
série bild et surtout la ville aussi et
dans un vent de fraîcheur où on veut
rentrer des trois plus agréable donc il
ya vraiment un courant qui entraîne la
ville qui est passionnant à suivre et
donc nous vous entraîne à travers ce
changement de mentalité d'attitude qui
traversent des trois actuellement
votre équipe
vous avez kg du sexe et valentin qui est
qu'est la 24e que moi je connais depuis
un petit bout de temps qu'ils étaient à
peine majeur quand j'ai quand j'ai
rencontré et puis vous avez que d'autres
équipes
bâle a du coup on a on a recruté pas mal
du coup tu te doutes pour le projet que
c'est moi j'ai besoin je rejoins
valentin il ya quasiment deux ans de ça
parce que ben comme tu as dit wendel
longtemps qu'ils surent explique
d'affaires du coup il prend un peu qui
prend l'envol de sa carrière
journalistique avec de moins en moins de
temps pour s'occuper de son bébé pickton
du coup c'est un peu moi qui gère
pendant que pendant qu'il se concentre
sa carrière on a en a du moment dans la
pierre pierrick louis raf qui s'occupe
de la rédaction de l'article c'est avec
nous met sur le compte en lui-même on va
retrouver ou valentin ou mois
essentiellement depuis quelques temps on
nous mettrait sur nos diplômés seront
mes travaux petit à petit et puis nous
avons entendu cookies qui devient un
journaliste pro plus que ça et
ça devient a vendu on peut on peut dire
y devient courant et moi je me dis que
j'ai lu pour vous calade adr vraiment ça
va ajouter trop content de voir de voir
alan décroche un poste d'assistant ses
effets dingue c'est vraiment dingue
chose que vous prouveront être produit
en tout cas nous la communauté parce
qu'elles ont la cote et baskets francs
en france on est très fiers de lui c'est
incroyable et j'espère vraiment toi qui
fait réussir j'ai vu ça il y avait un
bel engouement à la défection pour ceux
qui ont raté l'info a rejoint est devenu
scout pour la fête de sainte thècle a
donc dans une belle conférence dans la
doublure sicilienne conférence gonzaga
la fac a sorti ce teen ager l'adjanou
williams donc au programme et il va
pouvoir vivre son rêve américain en
californie ce petit [ __ ] là
non c'est on est vraiment hyper content
pour lui et l'arbre généalogique
envergure dans le monde professionnel
grandi un petit peu avec nico aussi donc
écoutons neo hyper excité pour son
projet ça qui est cool c'est que la
nouvelle génération qu'on voit beaucoup
jour twitter qui au début sont des
analyses twitter deviennent journalistes
pro deviennent des scouts travaillent
dans des équipes et tout donc c'est on
peut on peut être fier de nos gars et et
voir que l'engouement porté par les gens
je rends ti réseau sur un oiseau blues
50 caractères 150 caractères permet
d'ouvrir des carrières et des rêves donc
c'est ça ouais c'est vraiment bien ces
différentes
je te dis merci pour ce live merci à toi
pour faire vous
on s'est bien marré et on se retrouve
pas au goût de tous bientôt pour en
faire un début de l'année devrait
espérons le avec avec avec plaisir et
une finition a échu on sait on s'excuse
d'avancé de nous pu être un de vos
fameux lion cli fidèles mais vous en
avez d'autres qu'arrive j'en suis sûr
que c'est ça c'est ça on va voir on va
avoir peut-être les lunettes qui rompt
pas de pic jusqu'en 2027
on va leur tomber dessus on mesure le
chat de touggourt gm des bulls non non
non moi j'ai eu la petite vie de
campagne laissez moi tranquille sans
pression moi je pars à lévis a aucune
conséquence derrière donc ça me va très
bien bon écoute et des bisous prenez
soin de vous passer une bonne semaine on
se retrouve vendredi prochain seront
vers coeur pour un nouveau stream et on
vous a compris